hello i'm christopher plummer and i'm so
excited to be sharing this new trailer
for my upcoming movie the man who
invented Christmas which is coming to
theaters everywhere this Thanksgiving I
hope so much that you like it and if you
don't humbug to you
[Music]
god bless us everyone
follow
[Music]
so he's had a couple of flops well who
hasn't you have a new book in mind
oh of course he does my lamps gone out I
ran out of ideas are we in trouble no of
course not I have told you not to
disturb me when I am working Christmas
Eve the spirits pour into the night
we'll hear mr. Dickens pickpockets
streetwalkers humbug those people don't
belong in books miser and on Christmas
Eve he meets some kind of supernatural
guides desert hammock tried humbug a
Mises lament Christmas ghost story
Christmas song Christmas ballad some
another get the name right and the
character will appear as scratch
chuckle window I think I'm made of money
mr. Scrooge how delightful to meet you
sad sorry I'll come later Sam you and I
are gonna do wonderful things together
[Music]
how do you think a world come alive I
can almost see and hear them people even
if you'd already with it we couldn't
possibly get it printed and distributed
in only six weeks if I can't finish it
I'll never write again the characters
won't do what horn
actually guess what
from a season of hope we won't shut out
nothing and everyone will be welcome
I have to get to the printers by nine
o'clock but you still don't have an
ending very Merry Christmas to one and
all that's enough back to work god bless
our everyone
you